get it cat lasagna Garfield the famous
cat who loves lasagna oh yeah I got it
but don't worry he didn't keep the
lasagna lasagna is actually not good for
cats to eat today I'm worth it
we're gonna be trying three lasagnas at
three drastically different price points
to find out which one is most worthy at
its price I grew up eating a lot of my
mom's lasagna which I love but it's a
dish that I almost never order out at
restaurants and I'm the opposite
actually
we don't make lasagna at home but it's a
treat when I go out and we're off to our
first lasagna yes we're going to pasta
sisters where we were in season 1
episode 2 we are going there to meet
with Francesco his mother all the pasta
sisters and we're trying to lasagna at
their new location out in Culver City
they have bathrooms now and wine you
know they say about lasagna where they
say don't get any Anya who says that
you've been on worth it once before
after the first video we had the line
outside the door for a year and a half
and I gave us the opportunity to expand
past the sister to our second location
we have wine and beer now and we had a
couple of dessert options too same
family it's just bigger so let's talk
about the lasagna where's this recipe
come from I know this recipe from when I
were kids because I was making with my
mom we put a little bit of volunteers on
the bottom our Bolognese cooks for nine
hours the same way grandma used to do it
though the meat and veggies simmer
becomes soft creating this harmonious
fantastic flavor our lasagna is very
thin pasta inside so you don't have a
really strong bite or a chewiness of the
pasta but it's more soft that it kind of
melt
your mouth and then we put the first
layer we cover completely the first
layer and then we put a bechamel
bechamel is milk butter and our support
and usually me and my brother eat all
the leftover in the party you eat with
the spoon we take the pot and we lick it
we ruined a lot of people's life please
explain people are coming saying up you
know my wife lasagna is the best I'm
gonna try yours but and the next day
they were coming back saying don't tell
my wife but this is the best lasagna
ever had you put in the oven I become a
little crunchy everyone wants that side
the one day is a little bitter so you're
all usually fighting over the corner
piece yeah you're back at pasta sister's
round two with a bathroom with wine and
the original pasta sisters very close
quarters sitting over a table about this
size
now we're spread out we're outdoors the
Culver City breeze sipping wine unless
the afternoon wine so I'm going straight
in for the end right now Oh layers
chairs
really good I've never had such a soft
okay I also had the crispy bits on the
end and that sealed it for me it is so
soft it's like it's a drinkable lasagna
this might be the best way to deliver
pasta to your mountains you priests
stacked it you know you're like
pre-constructed
a delicious bite it's so efficient it's
already I know no I will not slow down
it's time to have some chocolate salami
chocolate salami is a dessert that we do
in the north of Italy there is no meat
it's just the shape you usually slice it
yeah so these are two different cookies
this is the wheat and this is the butter
cookie and we're also gonna try the
chair museum my favorite one oh yeah
thank you a little crunch of cookie it's
great No Oh what if you dip the salami
in the tiramisu we're painting the world
here I gotta go
it was great seeing the pasta sisters
again especially Francesco who refers to
himself as the most beautiful sister
lasagna fact lay it on me like a sheet
of lasagna in 2006 a man in Germany set
a world record by eating twelve point
six ounces of lasagna in 30 seconds at
first I was like that's not impressive
that's less than a pound of lasagna I do
that regularly in 30 seconds I do think
my giant flaw is I think things are
easier than they actually are but it
does sound pretty easy this shotgunning
lasagna we're now on our way to see Gino
Angelina at Angelina Osteria where we
are going to see his green lasagna how
much is this lasagna over $20 okay it's
got a lot of green what sort of food do
you serve here at the Osteria this era a
lot of the regional Italian food nice
quality and simple recipe
Sam Piero cicala as myself ten year kiss
with me I'm very happy so this lasagna
recipe is your grandmother's loss I
dedicate to my grandmother a lasagna
noodle Villa I think I'm good
competitive with my grandmother you
think should be articles on you made I
think so was your mothers and
grandmothers lasagna also green yes I'm
from emilia romagna and roma especially
they make green ragout bechamel
parmigiano a green path is the same when
your mother and grandmother were
originally making this recipe it wasn't
exactly spinach that they were using to
make the pasta green because sometimes
we don't have speed I say they have in
the garden yes they don't have you go
around the land and you find all these
herbs
Green leave it was wild like different
wild greens yes they boil it at the time
didn't have the blender
I like the mortar yes Wow you're going
up Italy was only something you ate out
at the restaurant a lot we don't know
that lasagna because they make home when
you go to the rest will something little
different the fried spinach on top where
did that come from they give little
crunch make little different
lasagna cheers Steven here's to you oh
that's delicious it's very crisp
can we go with the focaccia this is my
favorite kind of stuff by the way what a
basket at the start of your meal that's
amazing I snack on saltines all the time
it's almost like if saltines had our
bread quality look at this spinach have
you ever seen spinach like this before I
have not sure Steven chairs oh man why
are they not selling bags of this in my
every store oh I have to have a little
spinach leaf on top oh crap I know you
said this is a plastic lasagna but I've
never had a lasagna like this in my life
the color is ridiculous right it is
literally like a lasagna guava tree
right now okay oh wow
so we have a disabled Metro we cooking
in the mood oven we start with Dufferin
your kitty we use a whip it up on inside
and then we finish with the balsamic
aged vinegar period only Oh
oh my quad Jersey drew coming out oh my
god is he drew this dish reminds me that
we are at a very nice dinner spot yeah
because I kind of associate was Anya
with something that I eat as a kid and
this is like look this beautiful date
night lasagna oh great my lasagna
that's are you following this that was
delicious
whoa bring another chefs kiss when you
do it though it doesn't sound right I
think you're doing too much
sorry nothing when you're kissing that's
a peck if you love it you gotta express
it that does it for our lasagnas in Los
Angeles we're now on our way to
Philadelphia to have our very last
lasagna oh geez take Cheers okay my
cheese hmm I feel alive was on your back
lasagna effect Garfield comic strip
creator Jim Davis has said that he
wishes he had made Garfield's favorite
food pizza because lasagna is more
difficult to draw I'm glad it's stuck
with the lasagna there are plenty of
cartoon characters that love pizza now
wait for this though when asked why
garthe's favorite food is lasagna Davis
explained that he just thought it would
be funny but as it turns out I hear from
people all the time that their cats love
lasagna huh all right it is a delicious
lunch but for dinner we're going to see
Scott at the hungry pigeon where we're
going to have a family serving of
lasagna also we got a cheesesteak for
Adam Adam here you go what type of
restaurant is the hungry pigeon the
hungry pigeon is a farm-to-table
restaurant but we take it really
seriously so the sourcing is a huge part
seasonally focused ingredients local
focus ingredients all the vegetables are
right from around here we buy whole cows
the trim goes to burgers at lunch the
steaks go into dinner at night but in
general it's supposed to be simple food
that is very craveable we modeled our
breakfast sandwich off of McDonald's
breakfast sandwich we don't need a
mass-produced thing to use the local
really creamy Jack cheese so we made
like a hash brown that can go on there
too and then we make our own sausage in
the end like it's just a real nice fancy
Egg McMuffin
yeah we're really thinking about what's
the cool thing to do we're always kind
of going for like what do you actually
want to eat that exactly goes into our
lasagna never happened today the
ultimate comfort foods it's geared for
about four to six people it's like
basically classic lasagna as though some
people might argue ricotta versed
bechamel I like the ricotta version I
just think it's nice and also we make a
very nice ricotta out of local milk the
quality of ingredients means a lot to
because there's a lot of bad lasagna out
there but bad lasagnas like bad pizza
it's like it works and then we use a
little bit of the local cheese we have
because it's very creamy and like easy
so lasagna is a dinner only item it's a
labor-intensive process it has to be
reserved 24 hours in advance so we're
drinking a Negroni a classic Italian
aperitif but this one has a vintage
Campari so it costs $30 $30 each one
cocktail and we have a high-end Negroni
which is served with a Campari from the
1970s which is pretty special and damn
expensive
so these together equals that
Oh interesting aperitifs are designed to
whet your appetite makes you salivate
makes you crave and here we have one of
the most craveable foods I love a dish
that's served in the vessel it's cooked
em look you can see where it's bubbled
over this is the witch's cauldron of
pasta you see that burnt edge right
there yeah let's do it
Wow thank you whoa okay now I'm getting
the full scale this just reminds me of
the very first time I saw photos of the
earth cross-section yeah the crust the
mantle whoa yeah I know look at the
corner on that I can't wait I still do
it
yeah this is more similar to the lasagna
I grew up eating which has cheese
between the layers and on top you gonna
go across with me yeah let's crush let's
take a little piece here you have the
best-looking crust I've ever seen on all
of you're about to be mine more this is
a boat of meats oh why is crispy stuff
so satisfying I don't know I almost
brought up at long hots I'm very curious
what that adds to the game here it's
like an in-and-out when you get the
little cup of pickled peppers alongside
your burger is this date food says Adam
it's probably not first date but it's
probably tenth date whatever the
opposite of small talk is that's what
this food is yeah it's around at our
Philadelphia experience that's a pretzel
dig in which lasagna
what's the most were that see you I just
give him price point I have to say am i
worth it winner I'm sorry to do this
again it's pasta sisters that place is
crazy having a glass of wine in a
lasagna in the afternoon that to me is a
corner slice of heaven I am a hungry
pigeon and I love the holy vision but I
think my worth that winner has to go to
pasta sister
a simple mom style boom Adam who's your
worth of winner Adam says pasta sister's
Annie who's your worth it winter season
six shout out oh these are alert next
week is the first-ever double episode of
worth it double the food double the puns
see you next week
[Music]